now to recap we are checking if some
number n is prime by doing a trial
division here is the square root of N
and here is three starting at three and
we were hopping along by two up until
the square root of N and at each point
in the way checking if that number
divided n now so far people have been
trying to reduce the number of steps we
take by perhaps starting later and
taking larger steps now I just want to
pause here and let's think about what is
the ideal case for a trial division
algorithm what is the best we could
possibly do if we got very creative and
are stepping well remember any number n
has some prime factorization right and
let's say the square root of n is here
we actually only need to step on prime
numbers that would be the best we could
do because we know if we step only on
Prime's we will eventually find a factor
prime factor if it to composite the
question now is how efficient is this
method because it seems like we have a
perfect solution now if we wrote a new
algorithm which first just called the
sieve let's say the new algorithm is
calculating if n is prime it could call
the sieve and generate a nice long list
of primes for us and then we would have
our trial division which would use this
list of primes so it could hop along and
hit only Prime's up until the square
root of n wherever that is so what's
wrong with this well we can visualize
the time complexity or the number of
steps taken and remember I did so by I
coded up this algorithm and I put in a
step counter inside each loop so we have
let's just say step plus plus means step
plus one here and inside this other loop
there's also a step counter step plus
plus so these are all constant operation
is checking if and and marking so we
just have a step counter inside each
loop and now here is a comparison on the
far left is our old trial division
method in the middle is our algorithm
just calling the sieve to generate all
primes up to n and on the right is this
proposal where we just call the sieve to
generate Prime's up to the square root
of n and then call trial division just
on those Prime's and let's see what
happens with small input as we can see
initially the the sieve takes many steps
so we've been the modified version on
the right is actually slower than trial
division and as the input grows the
number of steps in the sieve grows even
faster so let's just forget the middle
and compare trial division versus the
sieve up to the square root of n plus
trial division and here we can see the
old trial division method is much more
efficient the number of steps in our
sieve to square root of n plus trial
division is growing much faster so it is
actually not an improvement and below is
the program I use to do this comparison
and there is a recording explaining how
I set it up but now you may be wondering
well what if we calculated the Prime's
in advance so the first step would be to
let's say build an array of primes and
store it on a hard drive and then our
algorithm would just do trial division
and it would know how to hop on Prime's
only because it would be reading from
this proposed prime List and perhaps our
prime List stores all Prime's up to 20
digits or even a hundred digits why
can't we do this well the problem is
limitations in memory when we enumerate
lists of numbers which we'll explore
next and just for example let's say we
were doing this by hand we calculate 5
was prime we
five on a piece of paper and we store it
in a filing cabinet then we get seven we
store that in the filing cabinet nine or
eleven sorry
into the filing cabinet and then we have
a filing cabinet full of prime numbers
this is our think of it as a prime array
now how big would this filing cabinet be
if say we wanted all Prime's up to 20
digits or all Prime's up to 100 digits
long could we even store this array on a
hard drive and understand why this
actually isn't possible we have to dive
a little deeper into how large does this
actually grow this prime array and what
is the size limitation of modern-day and
even future computer hardware